hey everyone
pumped to
share with you
a distillation of tony parsons the open
secret
there's a lot of good
juicy insight and wisdom in here
and
tony parsons and jim newman
have become
[Music]
really
dear to me
this last year
throughout 2021 i've been
really enjoying getting more intimate
with the way that they communicate
the nature of reality
and
we've had jim on the show it was a
really great interview
and tony we were scheduling on the show
we haven't
made it happen yet but i'm looking
forward to when that does as well
and
i'm so excited
i hope that this
makes
positive
beautiful
joyful
enriching impact
on you
and
we will just be going through the main
key highlights
and
if you find at times that there are
certain things that are sticking out you
can go ahead and pause the video and
take note of those certain things that
are sticking out if you'd like to you
can also write those profound
quotes
or things that stick out in the comments
below so we can build community there
and i look forward to also
finding
methods
alongside this style of distillation
that
will continue improving the experience
for you guys
so we have a lot of cool stuff cooking
and exploration and i would love to hear
your insights on how to improve these
book distillation videos as well
great
tony parsons the open secret
wholeness delighting in a creation that
is both constrained and liberated we are
only dreamed characters reacting and
responding from a set of conditioned
belief systems
in terms of actual liberation nothing is
happening the dream we are living has
absolutely no purpose
awakening emerges outside of the dream
outside of time completely beyond the
grasp of individual effort path process
or belief
oneness that enveloped me simply in the
wonder of what is
i feel it is the same for most children
apparently one day all of that changed
and i entered the world of separation
and need i had a separate mother and
father a name and a parent choice to do
this or that i moved into the world of
time and space boundary and exploration
endeavor manipulation and the pursuit of
pleasure and avoidance of pain i came to
own these experiences and believe they
were my natural way of being i was also
taught and came to believe that if i
worked hard behaved myself and succeeded
in my chosen or imposed job got married
had children and looked after my health
i stood a good chance of being happy i
did all of this quite successfully and
enjoyed myself at times but i also
recognized that something intangible and
fundamental seemed to be missing a
secret of some kind
being overwhelmed with the love and the
total comprehension that is absolutely
beyond imagination
the revelation that accompanied this
rediscovery was so simple and yet so
revolutionary that it swept away in a
stroke all that i had been taught or had
come to believe
enlightenment is absolutely beyond my
effort to change the way i live or even
of changing life at all
enlightenment is a total shift in the
realization of what it is that lives
i am already that which i seek all of my
desires are only a reflection of my
longing to come home
and home is oneness home is the natural
reality and it simply is what is
there is nowhere else i have to go and
nothing else i have to become
i try to explain the way in which my
beliefs about enlightenment time purpose
in my effort to achieve spiritual
fulfillment can directly interrupt that
oneness that is continuously directly
available
how the illusion of separation fear
guilt and abstraction can distract me
from the freedom that includes and
transforms these influences
effortless and natural it is to
apparently let go and be open to that
freedom
a singular and revolutionary leap in
perception once realized leaves nothing
more to be said enlightenment
fulfillment freedom oneness the same as
what i call liberation
awakening to enlightenment or of the
nature of what is is not something that
can be expressed
the separate experience are needed to be
absent for it to emerge
reinforcing the idea that the self can
find something that it presumes it has
lost
investment in self-identity that
continuously recreates the illusion of
separation from oneness this is the veil
that we believe exists it is the dream
of individuality
the temptation to avoid freedom through
the sanctification of struggle is very
attractive
life is not a task there is absolutely
nothing to attain except the realization
that there is absolutely nothing to
attain
i love his direct pointings
the realization of enlightenment brings
with it the sudden comprehension that
there is no one and nothing to be
enlightened enlightenment simply is
everything is oneness and all that we do
is get in its way by trying to find it
this reminds me of that adi chankara
quote
of i am in my village but need a road to
get to my village
i am oneness but i will get in my own
way to find oneness
those who have fully comprehended and
embraced enlightenment have absolutely
nothing to sell
the concept of journey applied at any
level school business enlightenment is
all a path to becoming reaching out for
results in time birth and death
reflected and reinforced the seeming
irrefutability of time's existence
passage and effect
as i believed in the existence of time
so did i also come to believe in the
limitation of my own existence as i came
to accept that limitation so did i also
come to believe that i needed to make
use of the period given
i had to do something achieve something
become something worthwhile during the
time that i imagined remained as a
consequence the idea of purpose was born
and together with it my expectation and
investment in what that purpose might
bring
i had to find a model of reality which
would satisfy my need to feel i was
making some sort of progress towards
some sort of goal
it's a greedy bottomless spiritual
shopping basket
any attempt to translate the
inexpressible into the doctrinal must
inevitably end up as a misrepresentation
such a good quote
this is a good one too
god says to the devil now that man has
found truth you will have nothing to do
on the contrary replied the devil i'm
going to help him organize it
freedom does not reside in one place or
another
i love this one right here
so good
the treasure that we seek is to be
discovered not in where we are going but
within the simple nature of the very
footsteps that we take
in our rush to find a better situation
in time we trample over the flower of
beingness that presents itself in every
moment
it's probably one of my favorite
tony parsons quotes
love that one
everything became timeless and i no
longer existed i vanished and there was
no longer an experiencer
oneness with all and everything was what
happened
overwhelming love filled every part
total comprehension of the whole
all of this happened in a timeless flash
which seemed eternal
what i saw was simple and obvious in one
way but completely untranslatable in
another
everything including me was enveloped in
a deep and all-encompassing love what i
saw was also somehow nothing special it
is the norm that is not usually
perceived
everywhere i am totally surrounded and
embraced in stillness unconditional love
and oneness
the divine instinct is continuously
available it is always at hand
in an eternal state of readiness like
the constant and faithful lover it is
ready to respond to our every call
it requires no effort
no demands no standards and no
preferences
its love is absolutely unconditional it
simply watches with clarity compassion
and delight as i move out for my return
i have never chosen or done anything but
have only been lived through i have
never taken one step nearer or further
away from that which is already
everything
in accepting my divine helplessness i
enjoy the freedom of never having a
pastor future i could call my own
once in the arms of the beloved nothing
matters and i can live as though i
choose
and rejoice in the letting go
until i have rediscovered what i am what
kind of existence am i trying to create
powerful principle of unconditional love
that is continuously functioning
entirely inherent but usually recognized
unrecognized
it is the very core of the living
paradox
unconditional love continuously
functioning inherent usually
unrecognized
all of existence is continuously
inviting us to remember what we really
are
i can't build until i fully know what i
am
we are dream characters in a divine play
reacting and responding from a set of
conditioned reflexes and belief systems
we are the dreamers in this dream which
has absolutely no purpose other than our
awakening from it
our experience in time sets up a
perfectly
appropriate manifestation exactly suited
in its grand happenings and tiny nuances
to the particular and unique needs of
our reawakening
all of this is simply and only a
function of that hidden principle
the one attractor underlying all
creation is awakening from the dream of
separation
never-ending opportunity to enter into
and beyond all phenomena and rediscover
the source of its emanation
the death of the mind body is only the
ending of the illusion of separation
the awakening to unconditional love is
immediate we are enveloped in our
original nature regardless of anything
that apparently happened
the parable is over the divine novel has
been written and regardless of how the
mind might judge not one jot could have
been different
the scenery evaporates and the
characters have left the stage their
apparent existence begins and ends with
the dream that has been played out and
yet nothing has happened for we are
already the ocean the waves the darkness
and the light the nothing and the
everything
i've been fascinated and waylaid by
abstraction painting the picture i would
rather have in preference to living the
experience i would rather not have
when i apparently let go
of that control they're simply the
listener and the sound
when the listener is dropped there's
only the sound i'm no longer there there
is simply the naked and vibrant energy
of what is nothing is needed all is
fulfilled
it is within the very alchemy of this
beingness that freedom resides
it is within this very alchemy of
beingness that freedom resides
listener is dropped and only the sound
remains the naked vibrant energy of what
is
life beckons me it whispers it calls me
and in the end it screams at me the
scream of crisis or disease is often
what brings
what will bring the rediscovery of what
i really am for it is difficult to
abstract suffering
i love this quote what i long for and
fear most is the absence of myself
what when i cease to own
it i liberate myself from its bondage
and see it simply as it is
a in any situation either i feel
separate or there is being and being the
self is no more and there is simply that
which is
so freedom self-constructing concept
cages and then dissolving them
liberation
so we indulgence and drama of separation
seeking smoke screens rediscovery of
what i am avoiding void
the unawakened mind reinforces self
who is looking the person or eternity
my thinking creates time and time
creates my thinking within time thinking
i maintain my illusory sense of
self-identity and separation
searching and longing to discover only
the one that is looking
seeing emanates from stillness
see moving character from eternal
stillness
creative thinking emerges from nothing
if i move beyond thinking where am i and
who am i
love it
patterns are only a confirmation of my
particular needs and beliefs and they
reflect that which i have not yet
rediscovered
hidden principle of unconditional love
inviting me to see another possibility
one part communicating with another part
i am relating to that which i project
out there apart from me there is very
little merging in the fullest sense a
communication between two projections
two conditionings two patterns or an
agreement to stroke each other's egos
the way in which i relate to others is
the most powerful reflection in the most
fundamental relationship of all
and that is with myself
no place for one part meeting another
there is no distance between the two and
therefore nothing needs to relate
all of our energy is merged into a
continual freshness in the celebration
of simply what is
communion of spontaneous giving and
receiving that can enlighten those times
when we return to relating
often there is silence because there is
no need to fill the void once seen as
threatening
these silences are full of simply being
together in an existence that is
continually dancing
these apparent experiences are only
oneness concealing and revealing itself
in a meaningless game of hide and seek
oneness concealing
revealing hiding seeking
the absolute expression of wholeness
nothing absolutely nothing needs to be
added or taken away
the invitation to discover that there is
no one who needs liberating is constant
already all there is is grace
there is
nearly always a someone to whom
everything seems to be happening the
story of me is always about what will be
never what is
it is the search for a treasure within
life never seeing that life is the
treasure
so eternity
infinite manifestation dependent
origination quantum entanglement know
someone to whom everything is happening
being uncaused unrelated and personal
energy which both is and isn't nothing
being everything both real and unreal
absolute being the relative formless
being the form all there is is this
absolute unicity nothing in everything
being that which cannot be known being
is totally without judgment analysis
wish to reach conclusion or to become
there is being or apparently being
separate
openness or seeming manipulation there
can be the simplicity and wonder of
simply what is or the apparent
limitation of our expectations all is
appearance all is already being
illusion apparently evaporates
separation self-identity hope effort to
know become continue is a kind of death
the end of something that was never
happening
i love it
separation was never happening and then
there's the apparent separation
that
dissolves that decontracts
into
oneness
recognizing itself as oneness
being
trying to catch air in a net
being on a path to try and get somewhere
being is what is and isn't and so
is not trying to get anywhere
already everything always already
when there is no longer that which seems
to stand apart then life is nakedly
passionately all there is
this is free fall life
full on not my life not anyone's life
but simply life
all is nothing being everything
love that one too
the open secret is not about our effort
to change the way we live it is about
the rediscovery of what it is that lives
yeah
i'm sharing my understanding of what i
feel is the most significant and
liberating insight that is possible to
comprehend
simplicity was one of the most wonderful
qualities that surprised me about this
revelation together with its
all-encompassing nature
it stands alone simply as it is and can
only remain unrecognized and rejected or
realized and lived
tony parsons
so pretty simple
that
you can either
realize it and live it or
not recognize it and reject it so either
you're a separate self or you're the
oneness
and
even if you say you're a separate self
you're still the oneness in the dream
state of separation in the illusory
state of separation
all is nothing being everything
life is the treasure
that we perpetually overlook
oneness is concealing and revealing
itself
in silence there is no need to fill the
void when we're with
people that understand the nature
the unawakened mind reinforces
self
in being the self is no more and there
is simply that which is
what i long for and fear
most is the absence of myself
love it
listener is dropped there is only the
sound
the one attractor underlying all
creation is awakening from the dream of
separation
all of existence is continuously
inviting us to remember what we really
are
absolute unconditional love everywhere i
am totally surrounded and embraced in
oneness
yeah what i saw simple and obvious but
completely untranslatable and then it
gets lost in translation
i no longer exist that i vanished and
there was no longer an experiencer
the treasure that we seek is to be
discovered not in where we are going but
within the simple nature of the very
footsteps that we take in our rush to
find a better situation in time we
trample over the flower of beingness
that presents itself in every moment
so good so good so good tony
any attempt to translate the ineffable
gets distorted
those who have fully comprehended and
embrace enlightenment have absolutely
nothing to sell
i love this one
everything is oneness and all that we do
is get in its way by trying to find it
life is not a task there is absolutely
nothing to attain except the realization
that there is absolutely nothing to
attain
the separate experiencer needs to be
absent for awakening to enlightenment
investment and self-identity
continuously recreates the illusion of
separation from oneness
single and revolutionary leap in
perception once realized leaves nothing
more to be said i am already that which
i seek
a total shift in the realization of what
it is that lives
the open secret everyone tony parsons
you can find the link in the bio below i
highly recommend checking out this book
and checking out tony's other books
i have them right now and reading
through them i love them they're really
nice
and i hope this
video
brought you value in distilling out some
of the
core essence of what
tony's communicating and it's just so
resonant with my heart and hopefully
with yours as well
would love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below
on the distillation
also maybe some of your potential
favorite quotes feel free to jot those
down below as well in the comments
like the video if it brought you value
help the algorithm subscribe to the
channel if you haven't yet
also share this video with other people
that you feel like this would positively
influence
and
that's all
beautiful the open secret tony parsons
it's also a nice short read
so you can get through it in a day easy
so
all right infinite love fam thanks again
and talk to you more soon
peace